[Music]
all right let's go to patrick and
cleveland what's up patrick
hey dr john how are you ballin dude 22
blades only impala what are you doing
that's good
uh i've been better but i'm glad to talk
to you
that was a good that was a good diss
you're like ah that was good
thanks man
i deserve that all right so what's up
so
i am just at a point like a breaking
point in my life where i feel like i am
just so
overwhelmed i don't even know who i am
anymore like i'm just ready to explode i
just i i don't even know what it's like
to be happy anymore and i just can't
take it anymore so i need some insight
yeah man well thanks for calling um
unpack that a little bit for me
well it's definitely a lot a lot to it
i'm definitely a mixed bag with a lot of
years of of trauma and a lot going on
but to get condense it all
i'd say the last decade of my life i
mean i'm 30 now and the last decade of
my life i've just had to constantly be
on
and why i just
well
i'm a chronic people pleaser and i and i
take on way more than i can handle okay
it's because i'm so driven and motivated
to get where i want in life hold on hold
on before we get going i want us to
begin to change your language as you
tell the story is that cool
sure so instead of saying i've had to be
on for the last decade
i want you to change the language to
have chosen to be on for the last decade
yeah
that's a good time we're gonna start
taking ownership of this okay and that's
the first that's the first line like
that's the starting line to
getting well okay
cool so you've chosen to
please everybody and to take on a whole
bunch of stuff and to be driven and
ambitious
um what are you running from like what
did somebody tell you that you weren't
gonna make it when you were a kid or you
come from a pretty rough situation like
you're you're running from something
what is it
i definitely am running i've been
sprinting but no you're exactly you're
exactly right i came from a really rough
childhood
my uh
the youngest of five boys uh divorced
family
alcoholics my mom died when i was 22 on
my birthday
i was molested as a kid numerous times
just a lot a broken broken family i had
to constantly
be a therapist to my own mom she
overtook my bedroom i had to sleep in my
dad's room she slept with a knife
it's just a lock yeah
and and what do you do for a living now
well um
i'm a musician i play in three different
bands and
i am in a sales job and it's finally
like a big boy job you know i've always
taken jobs in my 20s where it was like
okay i didn't really care if i didn't
work there anymore but
being 30 i figured it's time to take on
a career because i wasn't sure where my
music was going and i was getting to
this point where i was getting really
discouraged and now that i've taken on
this career it's becoming harder to
balance my music
because this is a lot more demanding of
a job and it's it's you know forced me
to travel for work and and it's really
affecting my my job i'm almost feeling
like i'm going to lose my job because
i'm so stressed right
um what is the um what is the
what does the music give you
well the music is my true passion and
i've always told people like
it's almost a curse to find your true
passion because
when you can't guarantee it's going to
happen or anything's going to come of it
it's like
you can't just go to college and get
your degree and just be like okay i've
made it it's like all a gamble yeah here
let me back up so here's the thing about
passion
we're passionate about what we're good
at and we're good at what we practice
and most of us practice what we're made
to practice when we're younger or that
we developed the discipline and skill to
practice when we're older
and my guess is you've been playing
music a long time and i grew up playing
in bands i still play in bands i love it
it makes me
so joyful there's nothing funnier than
than playing with a group of people
especially in front of a big audience
that enjoys what you're doing
that's something you like doing but
you're getting something from that not
just fulfilling your passion because you
like connecting with people is my guess
or you like making other people feel at
ease and that's the same thing that kept
you alive as a kid
and now that same defense mechanism has
become the way you operate in the world
and it's exhausting because your body is
still in fight or flight
see what i'm saying you can get
passionate about sales as you practice
it and get better at it and better at it
and especially if you're selling
something you believe in and you sit
down across a table from somebody or a
corporation you say i can make y'all's
lives better
with this product
dude that connection you'll get good at
that and you'll become passionate about
it i've never been on the radio ever
until two and a half years ago and now
i'm super passionate about it i love it
but i've been practicing like crazy and
i do it all day every day and early in
the morning and you know what i mean so
you'll get passionate things
they're getting something from music and
it's either a connection that you
finally feel like you belong with a
group of men and women that you play
with or in front of an audience or
you're talented i don't know what the
thing is you're getting
but here's the thing that thing that
you're getting is also killing you and
at some point you're gonna have to pick
one band
and let the other ones go
you got to say i i do this on the side
this is a thing that i love to do
but i'm going to work really hard to
become really good at sales so that i
can eat you see what i'm saying or blow
it all and say forget it i'm going to
write or die on this thing like i mean
if you want to be a great musician go be
a great musician and just know that you
know most musicians don't make it and
that's fine um you don't have to be rich
and wealthy to have a good life but you
got to make that decision and this is
the big thing
exhale
and so let me tell you this
i don't think you're addicted to people
pleasing
i think you're trying to survive
and pleasing people when you were young
kept you
from maybe not getting molested this
time
or maybe not getting your head kicked in
by one of your older brothers
people pleasing as a kid
you were told kept mom from killing
herself
that's not an addiction to people
pleasing that is an addiction to
surviving
okay yeah
and that same thing that kept you alive
as a kid is now wearing you out
right and so yes for whatever it's worth
man
i'm just some stranger on the internets
but i'm giving you permission to stop
your life's worth more than this right
yeah
and what you don't have is you don't
have a picture of what peace looks like
do you
not at all yeah so you're running as
fast as you can solving accomplishing
playing being good at these things so
that people will look at you and go that
guy's got it together i'm gonna tell you
you're gonna end up a salesman who's
really good i think every kid should
either do theater or and or music every
single child in the world because if you
can master a stage you can do anything
if you can be good in front of people
whether it's six people or 106 people or
a thousand people you can do anything
you're going to be a great salesman
because you know how to connect with an
audience
and you're going to get a million
dollars and you're going to pay off your
house and you're going to have a new
tesla and you're going to be married
and you're gonna find yourself asking
your kid to move out of his room so you
can go sleep in his bed
because those things won't heal you you
know what i mean
yeah
they're cool mile markers on a sprint
but they're not gonna heal you and dude
i want to pay my house off and i want a
nice tesla and i want you know what i
mean i want those things but i know that
those things aren't going to solve me
right
and the question i have for you is
do you want to stop
i don't want to stop
pursuing my dreams of music i've not
given up the fact that i could maybe
make it
really really far and i've already
achieved a good level of success and i
think that's where i struggle is i don't
i can't come to grips with the idea of
possibly never making it whatever that
means because you've put making it
exactly that's a great point by the way
making it like what who that bar moves
every time you get to wherever you think
you're going to go right every time you
sell out the theater they're like well
what about this place and every time you
sell the club then it's like why are you
going to move sell out this place and so
that line moves
but you think that you are going to feel
a certain way when you get to a place
and i'm telling you right now that place
does not exist
you are spot on is that fair
it is because i've achieved a lot of
these different things and every time i
get them i go okay what's next a friend
of mine tells a great story he was a
guitar player for a famous songwriter
and he was walking onto carnegie hall he
was waiting in the wings and he had his
phone he's put his phone away and he got
a ding and he checked his cell phone
balance i mean his
bank balance on a cell phone and it was
negative he was in the red let him know
that just been overdraft and he put it
in his pocket as he walked out to play
in carnegie hall in new york and it was
like i made it and i'm broke you know
what i mean like there is no or you get
off stage like that was awesome and then
you get back on the same stupid bus and
go to the next town you know what i mean
you know that
yeah and you'll make an incredible sale
and you'll feel so good and you'll go to
dinner and you'll feel good and you wake
up the next morning then you gotta go to
the gym again
and then you gotta be nice to your wife
and your kids again and then you got to
start the making new cold calls right
the whole thing just starts over again
and for some people that fries them out
for me i've learned to love that about
life
i love it
because my value isn't found there
and nobody may have ever told you this
but i need you to hear me say patrick
you are worth laying down in bed at
night just going to sleep
and you're worth loving somebody and not
worrying about if they're going to
molest you or take something from you
yeah and you're worth loving somebody
all in and not worrying about if they're
going to take their life and die by
suicide
you know what i mean and i know you
don't believe me i know you don't
believe me and it's you're fair not to
believe me your body's like okay that's
cute brother you haven't lived when i've
lived and you're right
um i share more of your story than you
know but what i'll tell you is this
there is healing on the other side of
this if you want it
but here's what that looks like okay and
this is hard you're gonna have to decide
to identify the things that kept you
alive as a kid that are now hurting you
as an adult
obsession with people pleasing trying to
do too many things saying yes to
everything
letting one thing that was really
important to you
dialing it back a bit so that you can be
successful in something else
those things
you got to identify them and choose to
intentionally set them down
and it's going to feel like taking off
articles of clothing in a public
intersection
you're going to feel completely exposed
and that's where the healing begins
yeah it's almost like if i am less
active on social media and engaging with
my fans i feel like i'm i'm backtracking
you know yes yes i'm trying to stop that
listen patrick it's a lie
it's a lie
all burnout is it's a real thing it is a
physiological thing it's not just i'm
tired it's
you're experiencing it it's when your
body says we have been fighting and
fleeing
for too long
we're out
i'm out
i've tried to get your attention with
anxiety i've tried to get your attention
with depression i've tried to get your
attention with
chaos i've tried i've tried i'm out i'm
just done
okay so your body just says screw you
i'm going home i'm taking my ball and
i'm going home
and so here's what you've got to promise
me number one you'll reach out and
decide for the first time in your life
i'm gonna get healing i'm gonna go call
a professional and that's what you need
you gotta have counseling i had to have
it people i love have to have it you're
there okay you need to go talk to a
professional and say i'm worth this
you also have to pick one of these three
bands and say i'm gonna sit this one out
i've got too much on my plate
are you willing to do that
100 which band
that's the struggle is which band i
choose because both of them are very
well all of them are popular and
demanding and it's just hard just hard
to pick
and then they're going to find somebody
else that plays guitar or bass or drums
and then they're going to go on about
their day
and you are too and you're going to feel
that twinge of uh i wish i was there but
then we're going to move on you know
what i mean and here's the thing if that
band goes on and becomes pearl jam
you know what you are alive
because you won't be on the trajectory
you're on
yeah okay sure
so um a couple of real quick things okay
and then i'll let you go
okay do i have your commitment to um
getting well
like i want this to be different
yes absolutely okay so you're gonna call
a professional counselor you're gonna
make that call today
i've actually already been trying to see
one and she's
understanding me and she's not giving me
a lot of skills sets yet but okay
on to the next thing
find somebody that you connect with and
if you don't connect in that first
session say thank you so so much i'm
grateful for you you're gonna make
another appointment um no thank you i
appreciate your time
right okay but i want you to go in and
say i've got some very serious childhood
traumas
i've got some very serious pathologies
that i deal with
sexual abuse physical abuse all sorts of
stuff and i'm ready to heal
i want to use that type of language take
that type of ownership okay
the second thing is is you have to get a
group of men in your life that you can
do life with just hang out
that could be your band
but often band becomes a performance and
it be literally and it becomes a uh
status thing
you need a group of guys you can prop
your feet up with and say i'm not doing
okay today
and they're not gonna go well what about
the band bro
you don't need that you need a friend
that's a banker and like one that mows
lawns you know what i mean
right it does different things um are
you married now
i am not okay are you interested in that
are you just ready to chill
well i'm i've been with a girl now for
four years and that was another thing
that's a side that i would like to get
your interest or excuse me your
intellect from but i know our time is
limited but she's pressuring me to get
married and i'm just not in the position
where i'm ready mentally that's cool i
mean four years is a long time that's
fair for her and that's fair for you
right um it is
let's set up another call for that one
so we'll go down that rabbit hole
another one here's the third thing i
want you to commit to
will you commit to making exercise and
sleep and eating a little bit better a
priority
and that i currently do so i'm there
good yep but you start in that order
sleep first everything comes after sleep
if i have to skip a workout i'm going to
skip a workout so i can get sleep
i'm going to miss that i still haven't
seen the new top gun movie i haven't
seen several movies that are out because
sleep is still the priority i haven't
had the time okay yeah i'm going to make
those priorities i'm going to miss this
gig because of sleep or i had this gig
so i'm gonna have to sleep anyway you
know what i mean make those things a
priority so that your body has a chance
to do the healing that it needs to do
cool
absolutely so let me tell you this
on the other side of this
fast forward two and a half years and
you're engaged
and if not tied up okay
i said that a real negative way you're
married and not tied up like your life
is good
the choices you make right now to decide
to be well
there is light at the end of this tunnel
if you want to make that journey and
it's gonna suck
it will not be fun and it will be worth
every single step because on the back
end you're gonna be able to laugh
you're not gonna have to put your back
into a corn like every time you walk
into a restaurant put your back up
against the wall so you can see the
whole restaurant
you're gonna be able to not get raged
out angry when somebody cut you off
you're gonna be able to lay your head
down and just fall asleep
in the arms of somebody that you love
and not worry about what's gonna happen
there's this piece brother does that
make sense
it makes perfect sense do you want that
i want it more than anything okay i'm
tired i'm right here i got it i got you
all right so we're gonna make that call
today and find another therapist and
hang on the line here i'm gonna give you
a copy of own your past change your
future it's my treat to you um read it
give it to your girlfriend y'all read it
together
and
um
begin this journey moving forward i'm
really proud of you for just saying
enough's enough so enough i've got to do
something different i've been there
millions of people have been there and
the first step is one of bravery so good
for you brother good for you you can do
it you can do it and i'll walk with you
every step of the way give me a shout
back let's talk about this girlfriend of
yours too